hi guys welcome to this week's episode
as you know having seen previous
episodes we are partnering with a social
media company called
cutie who are creating honest
and reasonable conversations online
instead of the the
dumpster fire that is the twitter feeds
and the facebook feeds of our world
uh this week we're hosting a
conversation around wokeness
and as you all know constantin is uber
woke he [ __ ] loves it
every day comes in he's a different
gender uh this
week he has come in as problematic
gender but anyway i'm always that one i
just put others on as well
yeah that's very very true so go on to
qt
click on the link which is in the
comments section
comment away get involved in the
discussion and then we're going to do a
live stream
on thursday and we're going to read out
some of your comments and we're going to
interact we're going to have a chat
so make sure you comment and get
involved in the conversation
enjoy the episode
[Applause]
[Music]
um so uh welcome back what we're gonna
do now is we're gonna bring andrew doyle
on stage if you don't know what
trigonometry is it's a youtube show
where we interview people who have
interesting and controversial ideas
sometimes
uh andrew's been on the show a couple of
times and but the last time we
interviewed him was
now a year ago and we did not know at
the time he didn't even tell us that he
was the creator to tania mcgrath
so please welcome to the stage andrew
doyle
thank you it's good to have you back
yeah it's good to be here
well uh tell us why did you create
italian mcgraw
uh okay so um for those of you don't
know she's a twitter character
predominantly and i started it about uh
in last april and the idea of the
character was to
kind of embody that kind of a radical
fourth way feminist
intersectionalist woke uh activist
and uh i did it as a satirical character
on twitter and then she got a book deal
and then then then turned into a live
show and that sort of uh
that's how it happened to sort of run
away out of my hands a little bit
and why do you think it struck such a
nerve because you started it last april
how many twitter followers does it now
have
oh it did like 380 000 i think but i
think what happened
was very early on because i did it sort
of as from
for myself you know as a kind of laugh
and uh very early
on what happened is it started getting
retweeting a lot and particularly when i
because i wanted her to be like a slam
poet
so because i was really i really like
slam poetry
you know it's so bad isn't it and it's
it's like it's really bad
and i love i love watching them do it
because they stand there and they sort
of do that really sort of
uh self-important pausing at the start
you know where like homonym i just got
to get into character
and then they launch into it and it's
just terrible and um
and it's always really earnest i love
that sort of stuff it's really earnest
and it's about important things it's my
my truth you know and so i thought it'd
be quite good
um for her to do that um and so
when i was writing the poems and putting
poems out there they tend to get
retweeted quite a lot
and then it started getting retweeted by
sort of more prominent what they call
amplifiers
like on twitter um and then she got
permanently banned
and um so she'd been banned a couple of
times right
um and then she was permanently banned
and i had an email saying
titania's gone you cannot come back and
then loads of people sort of kicked off
about it
and they emailed me again saying oh it's
all right she's back again so they undid
the permanent ban right
twitter called it a permanent suspension
which is a semantic contradiction but
um but they're not literate you know so
i
they're not though um and so they
but they obviously like so this is the
weird thing about like so she's had now
four
seven-day suspensions multiple one-day
suspensions
a full permanent ban um so twitter
obviously don't like this character
they're not gonna verify they won't do
anything like that so they hate the
character
because of ideological reasons um
because of course
twitter and youtube and google and
facebook all of these big
silicon valley tech giants are all very
woke and they all have the same
political mindset
and actually they have to in order to
get a job because there are thousands of
moderators
uh these companies who sit there and
there's these
woke people who sit there deciding no
you can't say that you should say this
these little mary white houses
in in in but they're just trendy and
young you know and they're
and they're deciding what you should and
what you shouldn't say and in fact you
have to
answer a questionnaire in order to get
the job to prove that you're
sufficiently woke
and that's why they've all got the exact
same mindset so so they had so they
obviously hate
tania you know and that but it was after
the ban just to make the point that
after the permanent ban
when that was revoked when the next day
i got 20 000 followers within 24 hours
because it's the streisand effect so you
ban someone and then they get amplified
so that's really why
we recently had the same thing with the
interview we did with posey parker yeah
it's a very controversial
gender there we go somebody watched it
um
so he got taken down from youtubers
quote hate speech yeah and then
two days later it got reinstated and
then now it's got 10 times the views
that it had
right exactly exactly but it never works
this stuff never works i don't
understand why if you know anything
about history you know
that censorship doesn't work it just
gives gives the ideas you're trying to
crush a kind of credence
and and so it it it's self-defeating on
their part
you know what i mean i think if they if
they if they hate what you stand for
then don't draw attention to it
well in not in uh weimar germany they
had
hate speech laws against anti-semitism
you could not be
anti-semitic right exactly i mean
goebbels was prosecuted all sorts of
nazis were prosecuted under hate speech
laws and they used it as a major pr
exercise and it gave them a massive
boost this is the big myth about hate
speech it's like you know if only we'd
had hate speech laws
to stop hitler no it helped him it
always happens like this and so and the
phrase hate speech doesn't mean anything
it means the opinion i don't like
you can't quantify that and for me i
this is why i do believe that hate
speech laws need to be abolished full
stop because
i don't trust the state i definitely
don't trust silicon valley
plutocrats you know billionaires
avaricious capitalists
who claim to be good and noble i i don't
trust them and i don't trust the state i
don't want anyone deciding
uh what i can say and plus people should
be allowed to if they hate things they
should be allowed to say so
it's not up to me you know the way you
deal with that is you attack those
people
like i don't want to live in a society
full of racists and homophobes and the
rest of it
but i'd rather they were able to say
what they thought they think
you know you know the current we know
who they are firstly we know who they
are
you know you don't drive them away so
that they sort of fester and never be
challenged
that's the first thing because that just
that just endorses their own views that
emboldens them
and the other thing is you know i i i i
don't think that's the best way to
i think any response to nasty offensive
speech
is is to critique ridicule
counter argue or whatever because that
way you can deal with it
but trying to shut it down actually
always inevitably
amplifies that and that's why i say this
a lot and i'm very serious about this
and
i think people don't take it seriously i
believe that the woke movement
and the social justice movement as it
currently stands is doing the pr
on behalf of the far right it is
amplifying and boosting the far right
without meaning to i think it's probably
well intentioned
but i think it's doing all the wrong
things and it is self-defeating
can i just say we've been talking for 10
minutes and we already spoke for about
three of them on the nazi so well done
everybody
we already got straight into sorry yeah
and why do you think the character of
titania has been labeled far right
i mean it's a nonsense isn't it oh it
absolutely is because people don't know
what far-right means
that's one thing people have stopped
reading books
and they don't know what so i think
there's big confusion about what left
and right means
i mean i had even the guardian called us
both right-wing comedians right
i think i mean you're further right than
me aren't you i'd say thank you
like but given that you are far right
yeah me being further right than you
yeah i'm pretty [ __ ] up well
no okay you're an old school lefty yeah
i'm a centrist right that's what i mean
so we're both not so if
you if you take yeah
if you take the spectrum of where we are
you're you know just objectively further
right than me but then the guardian is
further right than me so i mean
uh that's the weird thing when the
guardian calls you right wing you think
okay
but even the guardian doesn't know what
it means anymore but they don't i mean
i've had
like writers for the guardian calling me
alt-right so
yeah i'm not that's opposed to
everything i believe so you got
these labels they don't mean anything
people aren't educated politically i
think that's part of the problem
and titania is mocking the woke left
because the problem is that the woke
left aren't actually left
they they identify as left but they
don't know what left means they're
incredibly incredibly bourgeois
like the woke movement is it you know
this you know this to be true like
whenever you
you hear this stuff online or you see a
um an opinion column in the new
statement of the guardian coming from
this very woke perspective
invariably like nine times out of ten
that person is privately educated
really deeply privileged uh and they
just wanna talk about how oppressed they
are and and you know
that's funny ultimately that's really
funny
so let's dig in because we use these
terms left and right and no one seems to
know what they mean i'm not sure i know
what they mean anymore
so i guess in your sense being left wing
means a focus on class on class and
economics and money
right right that's what it's all about
uh and and
and and and you know the the the the
working man should have should own the
means of production you know this is
the idea um that you can just take away
class of money
and substitute uh race gender sexuality
and identity politics
is a complete misunderstanding of what
that's why
proper lefty sort of old-school lefties
they never sit comfortably with this
kind of identitarian woke thing
bernie sanders doesn't fit well with
awoke template jeremy corbyn doesn't
either when jeremy corbyn stands up and
announces his pronouns
it feels weird right not not least
because there was no one in any doubt
about what his pronouns were um and it's
weird there's a weirdness about it you
know
when jeremy corbyn uh you know does that
speech at loughborough and and white
people are charged an extra 10 pounds to
see it and you just think
this stuff isn't it it's not what he
really is
it's not what socialism is and it's not
what being on the left means
it's been sort of hijacked and i think i
think i put it down to class issues i
put it down to the fact that
you know seven percent of our country is
educated privately those people
they run the media the arts all the the
law
policing everything so they are the
influencers
but they're so but they they're this
privileged woke group and that's the
problem
and then you get this sense that this is
everywhere i mean like all we see every
day don't we get these articles
there's constant churning of woke stuff
down our throats and you you get
you start to believe that this is the
world we live in now and it's not
it's a small minority it's a tiny
minority of really powerful rich people
who are pushing this woke narrative you
know when kamala harris said um
recently uh that trump won't win in 2020
because we
the world is woke now and you and you're
like
no no you're woke and your mates awoke
people aren't the voters aren't and
you'll find out what come election date
you know this is no it's completely true
what you said so with
this movement seems to have started as
far as i can see from the last sort of
10 to 15 years
yeah and you say it's 7 but why do you
think it comes from guilt
the fact that these people are born into
great wealth they've had these wonderful
lives they look around the world
people are struggling and then somehow
they want to be able to feel better
about themselves whilst doing
i'd love to know why i don't know why i
i
s yeah it's it's it there's an odd
inverse ratio isn't it
like the more privileged we become and
the more uh
the more tolerant we become as a society
you know we live in one of the most
tolerant countries in the world
where we don't have these problems of
racism sex and homophobic i'm not saying
they're not there
but when it happens you notice it it's
weird because it's so unusual isn't it
it's it's uh you know whenever there's a
homophobic attack in the news
everyone is furious everyone is outraged
you don't get
these voices saying hang on a minute
maybe that was you know we live in that
really sweet spot you know um and i i
and yet for some reason now now that
we've reached that point of greater
tolerance
we are more convinced than ever or
certain people are more convinced than
ever that we're worse than we ever were
so there's this weird thing going on
i don't i don't know why and it's
interesting to me because in my show in
edinburgh which you know because you
directed it
i uh i love nepotism this is like
just about this is how it works well i
every night one of the things i would
say on stage is
we live in one of the most welcoming
open tolerant countries in the world and
as an immigrant i'm
allowed to say that right you know
and every night the crowd would would
pull back like i've just said harvey
weinstein is like a top lad or something
you know
yeah can i just say we're go anton is
our producer clip
that please yeah let's make it go viral
someone will do it so i i
what i don't understand is how that
there's this
terror yeah of just acknowledging a
fundamental reality
which is that while of course there's
racism and sexism and
sexism in my case with the actor actress
uh intolerance
all of these things exist yeah but they
they need to be taken in relation to the
rest of the world
right we are one of the best places to
be an immigrant in the world why is that
a controversial idea how they've created
this idea
that this is somehow so i think partly
it's what you were saying i think it's
partly to
that sense of guilt um partly it's due
with uh
our educational standards i think are
pretty poor so i
i i think that people don't really know
about history they don't know about
context
uh they don't understand where we are on
that sort of historical spectrum
um why else is it i want to get to the
bottom of it i'd love to know
why this is happening i think the big
thing
and i could be wrong this is supposition
right i think the big thing is like so
if you go back to the 80s and 90s
you had this political correctness
movement you know where we were we were
trying
to work out uh we were trying to sort of
agree on a social contract
about way the way we talk to each other
and that was a good thing and you ended
up with this kind of
there were mistakes made and people were
fired for the wrong reason they were it
was very very messy
but ultimately we got to the point where
you didn't have just open
expressions of homophobic people people
at least know that they're free to do it
but if they do it people aren't going to
approve
that's a really good position to be in
um and that kept going when it should
have stopped
i think so i think we're we've got this
that's why i never talk about political
critic i don't think what we're living
through is a period of political
correctness i don't use that phrase
i think it's something i think it's the
deformed offspring of political
correctness
and i don't know what you call that and
i really struggle with what to call that
um it's a weirdly authoritarian
um it's it's it's it's it's a coterie of
fantasists
it i remember right so it reminds me of
so if you go back to the sort of 80s 90s
there's a reason right there's a reason
why all of the stuff you're going to
read at the moment that's calling for
bands and censorship
and and uh and disapproving of comedians
and their jokes
it's always going to be a left-wing
press now it's always in the gardens
it's the stuff that you would have
read daily mail circa 1985
right that's what it used to be you used
to have like the right-wing tabloids
talking about
we need to ban this film we need to ban
this filth the movie crash
that the express and the mail called for
that to be banned
but that sort of stuff now you'll read
on the on the left so something sort of
flipped
uh and i don't know what what the i
don't know what that is or why
um maybe you have some insights but do
you see what i mean i think it's a
something's gone wrong something's
become twisted
and the values that we used to believe
on the left
have been forgotten and particularly
things about artistic freedom and
freedom of expression
and i think the fantasists are now on
the left where they used to be on the
right so
if you read like a column from richard
littlejohn back in the day and he would
be talking about how the country is
flooded with asylum seekers
and they're being washed with benefits
and tiaras and hotel rooms and diamonds
and like and and um
it was never easy to be an asylum seeker
in this country right it's
this was this fantasy world that he
lived in but now it's the woke left live
in this fantasy one this is a fantasy
world where everyone's a nazi where
they're behind every pillar
there's probably a fascist over there
there's probably you know like there's
fascists in the boris johnson using the
word surrender
is a dog whistle to fascists it's a
military metaphor
like it's that's what i mean about
literacy i don't i don't think
i i i think the work movement has lost
any kind of
it's it's like they're trying to fight
you know what it is like so they
identify as anti-racist they love racism
they can't get enough of it they want to
see it everywhere so so
so you know sarah silverman blocking up
for an anti-racist sketch
she's a racist yay we've found another
one
like and it's it's it's [ __ ] mary
poppins
right no so i'm i make this point
because
i tweeted us to tanya last august
i took that moment in mary poppins i
took a still you know where she's got
chimney soot on her face
do you remember that bit in the film and
i took a still and i said as to tania i
said this is blackface
this is disgusting julie andrews
indulging in blackface
she's a racist right that was in august
february of this year the new york times
ran an article
saying mary poppins and it's shameful
flirting with blackface
with a were they still from the same
scene
now that's the same as what i said but i
said it to take the piss
right i i there was an article two days
ago in the nation
talking about how uh thanksgiving is a
great time
don't forget about avoiding conflict
have a row with your trump supporting
family
get into a fight this was in the nation
i wrote an article that i
did a fake article as titanic last year
saying if i don't have a punch-up with
my grandmother over christmas over
brexit
i'll be really upset it's like it was
the same principle
and it really worries me that this stuff
is so easy to predict
it really worries me because anything i
can come up with at the moment as
ludicrous as it sounds
is probably going to come true right
that's scary not least because i don't
want that sort of power
i don't you're a comedian you do want
that sort of no i don't
i i'm i'm frightened i'm terrified by my
own prophetic
ability angie's modesty
no i'm don't have that but
there's a there's a question that i want
to ask you which is we see the left
gradually eating itself now you and i
both left these and we
you know we eventually want a leftist
government to come in we believe that
will make society fairer and all the
rest of it
but you look at the behavior of some of
the people in inverted commons on our
team and you're like well
you're ruining it yeah how are you going
to win hearts and minds if you just
start screaming at each other we don't
have a serious leftist option at the
moment
that's the i don't think we've we've got
that um
do i it's full of the when you allow
the woke movement to take over you are
allowing the bullies to take over
and it's never going to work i mean
that's what's happened with um
with corbin's band now and and uh
and the worst thing about these bullies
is they think they're good
so that's really scary um
and and then you get all sorts of
problems so i don't that's why i could
never vote corbin again
because i think he's brought into all
this identity politics nonsense i think
hiring monroe bergdorf to be your
advisor that's the lgbtqia plus activist
i apologize if i missed out one of those
[ __ ] letters
[Laughter]
and and that makes me think he's not a
thinker he's not a free thinker
i think anyone anyone who buys into the
woke movement i
i doubt their capacity for free free
thinking because when you talk to them
so i got an
argument recently with someone who
identifies as non-binary and as soon as
as soon as they started talking i'm like
i know your opinion about everything now
that's
that i think is really scary because i'm
no longer talking to an individual i'm
talking to an ideology
i'm talking to a cipher for an ideology
and i don't want to feel like that
because i like to treat people as
individuals
but it's like i but if i can predict
everything you're going to say or think
about anything you're no longer an
individual or indeed thinking for
yourself
you know i mean this was this was a
someone who who is a comedian apparently
and um i like you look to me when you
yeah sorry about that and goes to
various gigs
and she said to me like i go you don't
understand i go she
yes because she's female evidently right
no no i'm sorry like
the the thing about this is there is a
biological reality to gender
no well
listen i'm not okay
and that's the moment we get cancelled
okay look let me explain that so i'm a
i'm a
full-on liberal i'm a liberal so i i
believe you should be able to call
yourself
whatever you want identify with however
you want
and and i have no problem with that and
also there are people who are who
who genuinely feel in their in their
heart that they have been born into the
wrong body and want to do something
about it
and that is not that is something i
support wholeheartedly
do whatever you need to do right so the
idea of but non-binary as a label is a
form of self-identification which has no
grounding in reality
right it is the idea of it's actually an
incredibly conservative idea
because what you're saying is my version
of being feminine or being masculine
isn't right i'm not it's not i'm not
feeling it so what you're in fact doing
is saying that i believe that actually
boys should behave this way and girls
should behave that way
it's incredibly conservative you're
reinforcing conservative values of
gender i don't think there's a problem
with a girl a little girl being a tomboy
i don't think there's a problem
with a little boy behaving in an
effeminate way because i don't believe
in those issues i don't i think
so i i don't like people re-inscribing
the kind of conservative ideas about
gender that we tried to get rid of
that's what i mean so i so i'm so if you
want to call yourself
non-binary that's fine and i will
support your right to do so and i will
and i will oppose anyone who tries to
demonize you for doing so
but i'm not going to expect other people
to believe that it has any material
reality okay
it's a gender we've brought into this
faith-based idea that gender
is entirely a social construct right
it's not
it's a it's a very complicated blend of
social and cultural and biological
factors
and we don't always fully understand it
um so any kind of ideologue that comes
along and says no
it's 100 about biology or no it's 100
about
about a society and about culture
they're both
wrong and they're both uh unwilling to
look at nuance
right so that's why sorry this just came
because i misgendered someone right
that's that's all this came from you
know well you were talking about this
comedian okay so so what she was saying
was that
to go to a club and go up and
um like constantly be having to berate
comedians for the jokes they tell
right and and i was expected to say that
i support this i'm like
i'm surprised i'm surprised i'm being
punched to be honest like so the idea
and it's really kind of but i think it's
authentic i think this person felt
genuinely harmed and hurt by the jokes
that the these comedians were telling
and that's just very scary because
firstly that's just that
there's a misunderstanding of what
comedy is right but also there's a real
sense of entitlement there
that's what worries me about it's like
it's almost like the whole world is
different to what i want it to be so i'm
going to
demand not just persuade or talk but i'm
going to demand that the whole world
changes around me
and i just totally mistrust that if i
get married
tomorrow and i meet a say an evangelical
christian
and that evangelical christian says i do
not i do not accept your
relationship i'm not going to call that
person your husband
i can say well hold a minute can we have
a discussion about or whatever
but ultimately i can't say if you don't
call this person my husband
you should be arrested it's up to them
that's their freedom that's their that's
their conscience
so that's my that's my defining line the
liberal perspective is
you can call yourself what you want and
be whatever you want and say whatever
you want
but once you try to impose by law uh
your own values onto someone else then
i'm that's an illiberal perspective to
hold right
so that's why i'm not on board with this
idea of misgendering if someone wants to
call me she they can
right and i can say well that's just
factually wrong um
but but they i'm not you know what am i
going to do that's that's their call
it's a bit stupid but i mean it's like
that's their call isn't it
it goes back to that conversation you
and i had unleashed where before
you know the difference between men and
women was the hackist topic in comedy
yeah but now it's cutting edge and
they're
[ __ ] dangerous yeah exactly like the
moment you started talking about binary
differences between men and women there
was a real tension there's a real
tension in the room but why like it's
it's
you should be able to also we need to be
able to first we need to discuss this
stuff
right and we need to be able to joke
about this stuff right and by talking
about it and discussing you're not
endorsing hatred against a particular
group
right the opposite you're saying let's
talk about why you
feel the way you feel and let's see how
we can make this work um
you know i'm against that kind of
intolerance i'm against
uh hatred right but once you start using
language like you are erasing my right
to exist
what you're doing there is you're
conflating speech and violence and
they're very very different things
and it's a trick it's a rhetorical
sleight of hand and it shouldn't be
trusted
it's not very serious we're going to do
a q a in about 10 minutes but before we
get to that i
wanted to pick up on this thing that you
mentioned about
the woke movement reinforcing
stereotypes yeah it's like the joke that
titania made about
francis looking jewish right oh yeah
okay and i love jews because they're
cunning and all this kind of stuff
right right like it seems to me that a
lot of this stuff is
actually reinforcing a lot of
stereotypes for example
you're not gay because you don't buy
into it right you're automatically not
your gayness is erased by this
thing or black people are not black if
they don't vote for the democratic party
or whatever it is sounds like a joke but
that's what people are saying that's
what people say
yeah yeah yeah they're saying that to be
to be gay
is if you uh basically are on the left
[Laughter]
or you know like alexander the great um
he's very tolerant very tolerant this
idea that
and i think why i think it's so it's
rooted in a kind of homophobia and
racism you know because it's this idea
that
basically if you're gay you're all the
same aren't you or you should all think
the same way
you're not individuals with with
different ideas you know there is no
difference between
you know reggie cray and christopher
biggins you know
like you know it's like
it'd be a hell of a podcast andrew right
i find that i find that more homophobic
than what is often called homophobia
i find that worse i find the patronizing
view of minorities
i find it when people say you know we
had this it was at the back of ideas
where we had the debate whether someone
said you know about joking about islam
and like if you if you're saying that we
shouldn't joke about islam i'm going to
ask you why you have
such a low opinion of muslims frankly
why do you why do you why'd you look
down on muslims like this where you
think they can't have a joke
what's the matter with you i i think
that's and that's what i think a lot
that's why titania is really a bit
racist
big and she she is a bit homophobic
she's got all those prejudices that
she's projecting on everyone else
because i think the woke movement
even though it's weird it's a
well-intentioned racism
when did that happen it's it's it's it's
well intentioned
all of it and yet it's it it's it looks
down on on groups so it's like
white liberals deciding what people of
color should think
what is going this is this is the
weirdness of it you know and if they
were just
if it was malevolent i'd find it easier
to deal with
that's the weird thing if they were if
they were just [ __ ]
then well they are [ __ ] but they're but
they're inadvertently [ __ ] right
um some of them aren't nice like so we
have to we shouldn't let them all off
the hook
so a certain contingent at the woke
group are unpleasant human beings who
just want to exert power
um and a lot of them are comedians let's
be honest about it and um
they're just not nice they're bullies
who enjoy bullying that's what it is
and and the reason why they get so angry
about tanya is because it's someone
standing up to the bullies and they
don't like it
that's that's really what it is well one
person tried to agree with you during
that speech
everyone else doesn't give a [ __ ] so we
do you want to do one more question
before we take it to the audience yeah
so you were talking that you were
prophetic and uh yes you're
boasting i think but no you've gone
fully into character
so we are where we are it's the end of
the year
what do you think 2020 is going to bring
as far as we can see
okay i think it'll be a tory majority
yep
uh i think trump will win again uh
i know i'm smiling when i'm saying that
but it's like i i'm not a fan of trump
but part of me likes that it's annoying
these people
i do i know
i know there's a lot at stake
but it says it's the look of their face
you know it's like it's like
he triggers them like no other i mean i
love that he tweeted that picture of
himself superimposed onto rocky's body
he is really funny and that's it and
but by the same token i don't want the
president of the united states to be
funny
so i really don't but since he is you
know let's let's just like
i mean wasn't that thing with ellen omar
where she wanted to go back to to
to see her grandmother in palestine and
uh
and uh no she she'd applied to the
israeli
government and they'd said uh uh yeah
okay you can if you just see your dying
grandmother
and then and then uh and then she
replied saying no i'm not going to
i'm not going to dig or whatever it was
and uh and then trump said well the only
winner in this situation is
her grandmother who won't have to see
her
and that was
[Applause]
and that was tweeted out from
and it's funnier because it's the
president that
that automatically makes it funnier
right
i'm not a trump supporter i agree with
you and i think the thing that
if you if you if you pay attention to
the democratic debates
the democrats like you were talking
about kamala harris they've
decided that they won't woke enough
right
and they're going to go further off the
deep end right so that's why nancy
pelosi hates the squad
she can't stand the alexandria
ocasio-cortez of this world
because they whenever you think of
democrat
you're now thinking of her and that was
that's trump
that's trump's plan i guess it's a
really good call because
because woke politics is an electoral
death
it doesn't work people aren't going to
vote for it um they just convince
themselves in their little bubbles that
they will
but but in a way it doesn't matter to
them because i see a lot of the people
who are on that sort of momentum side of
the labour party and they almost don't
care if they win
because they have two narratives number
one if they win we won we're great
you know the world is a better place or
number two the world is racist it
doesn't matter
well yes that's it if they lose it
proves their point that there's a
problem
yeah we had james lindsay of the hoax
papers on trigonometry uh
last week and this is one of the things
that he was saying is essentially is
if they lose they will only see it as
reinforcement of their view they
basically say well we lost because the
world is racist
and terrible and bigoted right exactly
and that's why everyone voted for trump
again they don't they don't they
actually don't see it
they don't and they don't see uh that
when they lose the best thing to do is
to reflect on why
you lost and maybe with a bit of
introspection you'd realize that you're
the problem
um but they don't do that they didn't do
that after hillary lost they didn't stop
and think well why did we put up this
uh you know millionaire hawkish
character
who was really an unattractive uh not i
don't mean physically but i mean like
like an unattractive prospect as a
candidate
um this dynastic idea who felt entitled
to the presidency
you know what there were all sorts of
problems someone who was willing to play
identity politics and divide up the
electorate
according to race and gender and
sexuality and say you will help you guys
help the latinos and we'll help the
women and we'll help the gays and
and actually we know we know that that
doesn't work in terms of elections so
why
why not do that rather than go out on a
big march in [ __ ] hats
and sort of compound the problem why do
that that doesn't make any sense to me
you know you know same in this country
you know i guarantee it'll be the same
after
after labor loot i think they will lose
and after they do there's going to be
lots of people saying well there's a
there's a
you know we brought into this narrative
in this country and this is the real
problem the left have bought into this
this fake narrative
that brexit was about race okay and they
bought into this idea that we live in a
racist country
and we just don't and the more they say
that the more resentment they're going
to generate
from the vast majority of just normal
nice people who are sick of being called
racist
it's it's just not going to work what i
see in that is
and tell me if you agree that it's kind
of like almost a little bit like we're
living through the last days of the
roman empire
where we've lost so much grandiosity
but it is keep it light mate
[Laughter]
at least he didn't say a russian empire
it wasn't really that great
but it is we've lost confidence in
ourselves as a
as a civilization as a culture just to
such an extent that we're now being
encouraged to be
shame to feel shame rather than pride in
who we are
i think yeah i mean in that i'm not i'm
not nationalistic i don't
really have that so i don't i do
understand the uh
the idea but i also don't think there's
anything wrong with being nationalistic
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with being
acknowledging where you're from without
without sort of linking it to a sense of
shame or
sin you know i don't think that's
helpful either all right let's open up
to the audience if you've got a question
just stick your hand up and we'll try
and get as many as we can oh you said
the front go for it
go for it oh so he might be oh god i'd
be interested in your view on it's
interesting you say you won't support
corbyn
um because i know that broadly speaking
you're on board with
his economics yeah two questions
one i have a whole bunch of friends who
still refuse to believe that corbyn is
anti-eu
yeah and utterly deny any issue
whatsoever of anti-semitism
okay so because if i
the reason i voted for corbyn in 2017
the reason i liked him when he first
came back the reason i supported him
before he was leader is because i got a
sense from him that this is someone
who's not speaking through a kind of pr
machine he's literally saying what he
thinks and i found that really
refreshing
um i don't believe he is doing that
anymore he's the biggest euro skeptic
he hates the eu he's been opposing it
for 40 years consistently
he wants us out and i if he'd have just
said that i want
i want us to leave the eu if he'd have
said the truth which you
you can't really call yourself a
socialist if you support the european
union
those two things simply cannot work
because capitalism is built into the
constitution of the european union okay
it's a pro-corporate body so there is no
way you can those two things cannot be
married together and he knows that
but he won't do it and the reason why is
because he's uh this support base of
largely middle-class pro-eu
uh capitalists who like to who like to
call themselves left-wing that's that's
that's the first thing
and then when you see the interview with
andrew neal where that where andrew neil
says to him
uh see i've never heard corbin say
anything explicitly anti-semitic
so i'm very wary of putting that label
on to him but what i would say
is he was he was asked an example of i
think andrew neil quoted a obviously
anti-semitic trope
and he had to bully corbyn into saying
that's an anti-semitic trope russia
conspiracy right exactly so he's not
being honest there
that's so he knows that's an
anti-semitic trope anyone does so and
what he's trying to do is the same with
the brexit thing he's trying to keep
people in his party together because
there are there are people
who uh who let's face it
um have such a problem with israel that
it does tip over into that
into that world and he's trying to keep
them on side but he's trying to keep the
other lot on side and then with brexit
he's trying to keep the euro skeptics on
side as well as the uh
the pro-eu people so um that means he's
not being honest anymore that that's
so he's behaving like every other
politician and that's not why i liked
him
that's what i mean well you know an
anti-semitism thing it's an interesting
thing because
87 percent of british jews now think
that uh
jeremy corbyn's anti-semitic 84 percent
think the labour party is anti-semitic
a number of jewish mps have left the
labor party now
riddle me this if dianaba david lammy
and dawn butler had left the labour
parties claiming that it was
institutionally
anti-black and 87 percent of british
black people thought that
the labor party was racist against black
people would we be having this
conversation
in any way but we still should in a
sense in that i don't trust
these labels insofar as i i need some
evidence calling someone an anti-semite
as in calling someone a racist
or calling someone a homophobe is quite
a serious accusation
and i i need some specific evidence of
that which i haven't seen of corbyn
but i think i think the fact that he
won't
because you he i could tell from that
interview that he knew that that was an
anti-semitic trope he just didn't want
to say it for political reasons
that doesn't equate to anti-semitism but
it certainly doesn't uh it certainly
won't quell the fears
of jewish people right uh who else would
like uh
yes sir gentleman over there with your
hand up i'm afraid you're gonna have to
shout because i can't reach over with a
mic
it's actually a lady well done man uh
at trigonometry we don't see gender
thank you very much
just shout please not saying i'm not
seeing any masculinity in here
just curious the uh the free speech
stuff i'm just wondering how
we start to roll that back given the
level of
institutional charities hr departments
nhs schools that are all sort of jumping
on board
this you know curbing free speech and
and
trying to make people say certain things
compelling speech about gender and
specifically obviously i'm talking
yeah so i'm just wondering how we start
to roll this back because
we seem to be fighting we're fighting a
big tide here of
of of compulsive speech basically
yeah concerns me greatly yeah and you're
right to be concerned it's the thing
about
firstly i think we need to scrap the
quangos i think we need we need to stop
the government outsourcing powers
to people who will decide what we can
and cannot hear and see the example
i've given before is about the
advertising standards agency who decided
that certain
adverts that promote gender stereotypes
are to be banned
so that we're not i don't know what
radicalized by that i don't know what
that even means
so you've got like a group of woke
idiots in an office saying well look in
the volkswagen advert
there's a woman with a pram and that
might suggest
that women can be mothers and and and
then you'll have all these people
thinking that women can be mothers so i
think i think
so we get rid of the patronizing quangos
um but the problem is that it's so in
it's so in the publishing industry
the arts all of these things it's the
government there's
there's very few politicians who are
willing to stand up for free speech who
are willing to stand up and make a
an anti-woke argument and the only way
it's going to happen probably is through
legislation and things like that but so
the recent case of harry miller
who who is currently fighting a legal
battle because he was investigated by
the police for retweeting a transphobic
poem
um it is quite funny and it's like it's
and the policeman said to him we've got
to check your thinking you know this is
quite a famous case
and the problem with that is that um
that that's come from
the college of policing which is not the
same as the police there's it's just
a group of woke people who've written a
book but that is how all the police are
trained
and that's what all the police think so
you have to tackle that but the
government doesn't stand up and want to
tackle that
right so it takes one individual who
goes to a court case
and then when it gets to court the judge
is like this is ridiculous like day one
the judge was saying what the hell is
going on here
and also the judge was saying that free
speech is there to defend unpalatable
views that's what it's for
we don't have the conservatives and now
now interestingly
in the cont the new conservative
manifesto there is a commitment to free
speech
there's a there's a commitment to to uh
to uphold certainly press free freedom
of the press
which is new uh that's quite interesting
because up until then i
would have said that neither the
conservative because i mean theresa may
had a terrible record on free speech
theresa may kicked out tyler the creator
it wouldn't allow the wrapper title of
the credit to come to the uk because of
his lyrics
and then he did a rap about theresa may
right
that's great there's like a rap about
theresa may anyway so
um but also the labour party is
anti-free speech
explicitly you've had corbin threatening
the press
basically saying if we get in you better
watch out right and then we've got like
do all that sort of trash talk
and then you've got like um and their
freedom of speech they're just generally
speaking
they're not good on freedom of speech so
hate speech laws need to be abolished
we need to get rid of the electronic
commission section 127 of the electronic
communications act
but who's going to do it that's the act
by the way that says that if you
transmit or write something online
that could be deemed to be grossly
offensive uh you can be arrested
uh exactly um
many you know thousands of people
arrested every year under that under
that clause
um and some of them saying really
horrible ghastly things
uh but so what as in that's their right
um
not not that you shouldn't uh criticize
them for it but but
no i draw the line arresting anyone for
anything like this this is why joe brand
was um
investigated by the police for for an
obvious joke so this stuff you might say
is not serious
but it is serious because you've got to
be vigilant when it comes to free speech
otherwise you end up like canada
otherwise you end up like you do
you end up like um mike ward yesterday
it was discovered the comedian mike ward
who was uh taken to the quebec human
rights tribunal
for a joke he told about a disabled boy
um
and the idea being that this is such an
offensive joke and he was fined uh 42
000 pounds in the end after some legal
wrangling it they got down to 35
000 dollars sorry and then um he
appealed it and they've upheld they've
said he can't
his appeal won't be upheld he has to pay
35 000 for this joke
he's not going to do it which means
potentially he could go to jail
and he is not just some [ __ ] poster on
youtube he's one of canada's most
successful
comedians so you've got you know i mean
canada has a terrible track record
on on free speech uh it is now becoming
one of the most illiberal uh countries
in the west which is really weird
you know and i don't know with under
justin trudeau
who spends more time in blackface than
out of it hey
let's take a question from this section
if anyone's got one all right
oh yeah you've got a gender non-specific
person at the back
[Laughter]
uh i've noticed that i've actually been
self-centering
quite a lot lately where i've someone
sent me something and i think
oh that's funny i want to say a joke i'd
be like
that's gay but i don't want to say that
maybe you should be self-censoring it
it was an anime about volleyball or
something like that
volleyball is quite gay i mean if you've
seen top gun you know
if i get a type of success in my life
like say 20 years from now yeah
that's going to get the offensive
archaeology they're going to dig down
yeah he said that 20 years ago yeah
exactly like
do we just not say it or just keep that
quiet
or is it like look because then we can't
just joke about it well you should
always think about what you say
and you should always decide whether you
know that you know can i justify that i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that
i think where i have a problem is if you
choose if you've if you've had that
conversation with yourself and you
choose to say what you want to say and
then people are going to
attack you for it and hound you out of
your job i can't get i can't get on
board with that at all
um the offense archaeology thing is a
really scary thing is it so absolutely
anything
anything probably some stuff i've said
today could get me in trouble
um yeah
and and i i just but no more than that
mistakes that you've made like what if
i've made a joke and it didn't quite
work or maybe
i've i've said things which i don't mean
or you know all that sort of stuff and
then someone can sort of
find it and and and try and smear your
character but
as obama said we're all human beings
with flaws and we're not perfect
and the expectation of ideological
purity is a horrible intolerant thing
um but then the new york times just said
yeah but he's a boomer so he would say
that
literally that's literally what they
said so that's the level of debate that
we're at at the moment um
i don't i don't know like i mean when it
comes to things like
racial epithets uh homophobic epithets
or the rest of it what i'd like to think
is that we're sort of
we're sort of educated out of the month
when we're at school i think at school
is where you can be quite militant about
what people say
because you you said about because i
think to be an autonomous adult you have
to be well socialized
so you can't just have kids just
swearing and you know
you know taking gak and or whatever it
is they're doing you know
you can't have you've got to control
kids and make sure they understand
parameters and boundaries
i think when it comes to adults no [ __ ]
off they can say whatever they want and
do what they've made that choice they're
autonomous beings
you know so yeah it's a it's a tricky
one
um but i don't think anyone should lose
their job for saying a joke is gay
you know i think it's probably a silly
thing to say
but so what well what do you think about
this
idea of self-censorship because it's
something people ask me a lot as well
a lot of people and i know this from
talking to a lot of people from doing my
show
most people actually in the country i
think it's 73 percent of
british people think that i know you
don't like this but political
correctness has gone too far basically
right
so most people feel like to some extent
they are having to censor themselves
yeah but i know what they mean by that
yeah i know i know
so how do we break out of that as a
society of being in this kind of death
grip
of fearing to speak your mind so honesty
is a really good thing
i i think um saying what you actually
think is
is a good idea uh to a degree
um but i think like okay so i think in
our job we do say whatever we want
and we're very privileged but you don't
do that i wouldn't do that if i was
still working as a teacher
and i wouldn't tweet the things i tweet
or when i worked at the call center
like a lot of people when they work in
place they they tend to just they don't
joke very much anymore
because they're worried about what
people will overhear and and misconstrue
and
all the dangers that come with that you
get fired from mazda for retweeting a
billy connolly video stuff like that
so people like that that actually
happened so people are
are very nervous there is a so this is
why i'm very clear about this when
people say to me
the criticism i always get is are you
always going on about how no one can say
anything anymore
and i don't say that and i don't argue
that what i'm saying is we've created a
climate
where the consequences for being honest
can be so devastating
that people aren't going to do it and
that's why the polls are always wrong
because
if you have a mass media telling
everyone in the country if you vote for
brexit you're a racist or support racism
you know and someone phones you up and
says which way are you planning on
voting you're not gonna say well i'm a
racist dude
you're gonna keep it to yourself and
then the polls are misleading right so i
think you've got two
sort of discourses going on you've got
you've got what people actually think of
what they're
expected to think there's a thing called
preference falsification where what you
do is you articulate
the view that you expect to be the most
popular um
instead of the thing you actually think
and that's not helpful to anyone
because we need to have open uh
discussions and debates about stuff but
i'm willing if you want to say anything
i've said tonight
is is wrong or objectionable even um
then i would love to have that
conversation right
but what i don't what you're doing is
phoning the police and saying he
shouldn't have said this or whatever you
know that that's where i think that is
too far
out of interest if there's anyone who's
got a question who would like to
disagree with me that would be really
good
because i i do really welcome that oh
there you go
it's not a disagreement but just
something what did i just say
what's your anonymity for instance like
it's easy to be anonymous and say what
you want yeah but it's harder to kind of
put your name out there and say what you
think so what's your take on that
especially
right i suppose it fits into what we've
just been saying as far as
i think if everyone were just honest if
everyone would just open about what they
think they would reach a kind of tipping
point where you can't sack everyone
and and particularly when it comes to
the the excesses of the social justice
movement
because most people hate this stuff and
are sick of it and i was sick of being
talked down to
um if everyone just spoke their minds we
might realize that actually we're in the
majority
and this powerful clique of very of
privately educated
um bigots uh would wouldn't have the
power anymore and i think that's so
that's why
i think it's really great when people
and you end up with strange bed photos
so now i have friends who are
conservatives who i never
i never had conservative friends that
sounds awful but just because of the
circles i moved in
and now and now i've got lots and lots
of friends from all over the
you know with that event we went too
recently where like at lunch there was
um
the head of the atheist society sitting
next to an evangelical american pastor
right but they both agree on the free
speech issue they hate everything each
other stands for but they can talk about
this stuff and that's what we want
uh but that but that is that is that's a
weird situation to be in there isn't it
well you have and also i've started
meeting all these these monsters of the
right
you meet these monsters the people
you've told are absolute monsters and
you meet them and they're like
you're nice you meet them and you
realize that they're actually decent
people they've just been completely
mischaracterized
and this is what this is the big i spend
all my whenever i get into arguments on
twitter
which i shouldn't do right but whenever
i do it's always someone has
mischaracterized what i think
and misrepresented what i think and
they've said you think this you think
this you think this and
they're always completely so far off so
i end up
arguing from a position i don't hold
like
i end up sort of embodying this monster
they've created
in order to argue and it's it's
absolutely futile you know so
we need to do something about i again i
don't know any of the answers
but i think honesty is a really good
place to start
you know just saying what you think and
not being afraid of
more support than you think is what is
what i'd say and
the for the question that we always end
on every episode of trigonometry
constantine would you do the honours
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be talking about
okay uh there's lots of things i think
education is a big thing i think
um i think i can't i wonder if i said
this last time when i was interviewed
with you but [ __ ] off
so many times i know running out of
answers to that question have you
i'll be unoriginal but i do think it is
about critical thinking
uh i think it's about
i think it's about if you let people
know
it's about political debate it's about
argument it's it's that if you let
people know that once they've insulted
someone or shouted something
or pretended they think some your
opponent thinks something they don't
you have automatically lost that
argument it's it's over
you know so so trying to instill that
into people
trying to get people to think for
themselves and not according to an
ideological rule book would be great
um just getting people to challenge
their own ideas would be really good all
of this stuff
comes back to what you embed at school i
think right
not just assuming that something that
someone says is right
i'm terrified of people who cannot
self-reflect and cannot
think about their think about their
perspectives and why they hold them
i think that's really scary to me and i
see that a lot uh in in the woke
movement
um so yeah i think that's the thing we
should be talking about how
how do we make that change again i don't
know the answer to that but that's
something that if we could get to that
point
uh that would probably solve all of our
problems in terms of political tribalism
and all of that kind of thing but how we
get there i don't know and on that note
uh but guys thank you so much for coming
out
uh please please please give a round of
applause to alex marshall
give a round of applause to our guest
andrew doyle
and you've been absolutely awesome thank
you very much have an amazing restaurant
thanks for coming out guys
thank you very much thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the youtube
channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word